what would it take to restore your faith
in humanity
maybe it's seeing someone pay it forward
to a person they've never met or seeing
signs of generosity in places you
thought were only interested in making
money
maybe it's seeing someone else who
understands that it's not always about
winning sometimes it's just about
helping someone else cross the finish
line maybe it's something as simple as a
smile or a gift for someone in need or
an apology and the relief that comes
from it
maybe it's seeing someone reach out
across divisions cross cultures to find
new friends maybe it's finding other
people that realize just how silly the
world can be sometimes sometimes it
helps to remember that there are good
people out there people whose instinct
it is to protect the weak and the
helpless to be brave people who don't
hesitate to help a stranger even if it's
an inconvenience or dangerous or
requires a bit of undressing in the
process it helps to remember that this
instinct spans generations the young
people can act kindly without being told
to and that old people sometimes give
their lives in order to spare the young
sometimes it just helps to remember that
there is good in this world real honest
good